[Music]
and we're back
like we never
left so what podcast welcome back in
barry lord taco i'm brad hi guys
and i get the memo to wear a bonnaroo
t-shirt i'm very i know right i've been
missing you guys i noticed tacos i like
that hi david where are you
do you have a bonnaroo t-shirt i do not
oh wait that's not true i've got two
that barry gave me as um oh that's right
volunteer shirts great
shirts yeah they're wonderful but i'll
just never wear them i know you're not
too heavy they're that that heavy itchy
gildan shirt and i just can't get to it
man that's well
the real reason you don't is because
there's a really good chance brian stone
is going to be wearing his oh absolutely
and you'll look like twinsies because he
and i he wears it every day
he does
look we have so much to talk about we're
going to have we're probably going to
miss a lot so if we miss a topic that we
should be talking about please drop us a
comment whatpodcast.com or uh the what
underscore podcast on the socials there
is so much that has happened in the last
two months i have no idea how we're
gonna get to all of it but the top story
the lead is that i spent a weekend with
brian stone i know and lived and
he
thrived like i've never seen him thrive
in the world before like outside of
bonnaroo i've never seen him this happy
what guys wow
on cloud nine i've never in the 15 years
of knowing this kid have ever seen him
this happy i've i've in the 15 years
i've known him never heard the word
happy
i know put next to his name
even at bonru he's miserable oh yeah he
can't stand it
he catches himself if he's happy he's
like i gotta kick myself in the shins or
something because i've gotta sabotage my
life somehow how can i make this now i
will say
uh the first day
i mean the first second that he walked
in the door he goes where's the closest
liquor store
and so he walks directly to the corner
liquor store buys um cheap
gin and some
tango tan what is it called tonic water
yeah all right so he buys that and he
wakes up the next morning
and the second that we get on the train
he looks around he's like
i gotta buy more jen before we get home
man's got his problem
you just bought
a bottle
have you already gone through
a bottle and he said well i will buy
tonight
i gotta be prepared for the morning well
he is on vacation come on you know
and so literally we took another bottle
home um within the night the next
morning he's like i gotta buy more tonic
water it was like this endless parade of
needing to buy more gin and tonic water
like after three days the wife looked at
me and she goes
i'm worried
well as long as you knew where the
liquor store there was no need to worry
but i i don't worry i know what she
meant
so
so um so he has a wonderful weekend he
walks and i swear to god the man walked
because i i tracked it 70
000 steps
in four days we walked 45 miles
um he practically did everything that
the city could have thrown at him he
loved every second of it even the things
that i thought that he was gonna hate
like you know weirdos on the train you
know
or this place is a dump why does it
smell like pee
uh i didn't get anything i swear to god
i didn't get one complaint wow
something's bad i was wrong compare it
with i mean compare it to what a year
ago and when he came to visit you in new
orleans
i mean everything was a complaint i mean
everything that happened you had
neighbors that were ready for him to
leave right
the neighbor said i don't ever want to
see them
so then the best part is we go to uh we
go to the mets game i'm a huge mets fan
he's a big braves fan so i took him to
um to citi field
and
it was the fifth of a five game series
the mets have just dominated them for
three games right they lose one game
because a pitcher kind of um you know
takes a dump in the first ending but
other than that the the braves really
get swamped in this series so we get
there on sunday we get there early we
traverse the ballpark oh my god his eyes
are like
kid on christmas they're wide and
big and he's got this creeping smile on
his face it's getting a little bit wider
every minute and
we get into the ballpark the game starts
and he is just
in awe
and by the end of the game after
watching three no four straight games
with him after taking him to a mets bar
and watching one game of the double
header
i looked at him and i said
you love this team don't you
and he goes
no
wow oh my god
guys he loves the mets wow he loves the
mets he loves city field he loves the
players he loves buck showalter i mean
at the end of it he's like you know what
i think i could root for the mets if
they made it to the world they're a good
team they're very very good how
did this happen wow
okay who showed up at my house okay so
for people who don't know and uh and
brad you're gonna laugh but brian has
his own podcast called stone on air
people might want to
check that out this week because i'm
going to guess his story is going to be
180 from what you're telling because he
can't do that that's because he won't
tell he won't do it
he will not be able to tell you exactly
what happened yeah um yeah it's going to
be something i'll tell you
i tell you he's so bad about this
because i was on his podcast one time
and i told him the truth about a story
that he had constantly gotten wrong
and what happened casually to that story
it got deleted from the podcast yeah
well it's good to be the king
it's so funny because
he's he ha it's funny i was talking to
somebody about him just yesterday brian
has uh that classic
90s era kid growing up where if it
didn't happen
when he was a kid that's right it didn't
happen it didn't happen didn't exist
yeah and it wasn't the greatest ever
that's right barry after after you said
this to me i've never been able to look
at them the same we watched that 99 uh
woodstock documentary right the first
one not this latest one and barry came
on this podcast i don't know if taco
remembers but he said
brian stone is every kid that went to
woodstock 99 because he went to
woodstock 99.
angry
but they don't know what they're angry
they have no good reason and that yeah
and that is quintessential brian that's
exactly right i don't know why they're
mad they just want to be mad because
they just know that they're mad about
that and i've said to you too he's he he
he is so mad that he's not 14 years old
perpetually
and discovering pearl jam for the first
time every day
that's all he wants in life he wants to
be 14 and discovering pearl jam for the
first time
and well he's gonna be blown away when
he finds out that i
might be going to see them at the apollo
theater oh don't tell him that
oh
i know i know oh don't tell him that i
know well you've already died you've
already stunned me by um you know he
smiled
and and you used the word crack smiles
he was very happy wow
i can't i mean it might have been the
greatest trip of his life i cannot wait
then to hear this podcast because it's
not going to be that it's going to be
horrible it's gonna something i mean i
think that he's going to to acknowledge
how much he liked it but i think that
he's gonna have trouble
not wedging in the things that he hates
he's gonna have to invent some things
that he hated so that he can wedge them
in just to balance out his
his inability to be happy yeah that's
right
yeah that's gonna be fun
man there's a good trip so i i can't
believe that's where we're starting
because the place i was i'm sorry
i feel like i don't know well i do
because only because and i don't know if
you were going to bring it up but not
only did you guys go to the bridge you
went to uh rage right you went to go see
rage against the machine oh god yeah oh
my god guys so i'm going to bring this
up later when i start making some
bonnaroo demands but this was one of the
great shows and you know i don't i'm
with brian on this one i don't like the
hyperbolic greatest show ever guy
but this was one of the great shows i've
ever seen in my life
and partly it's because i've never seen
rage before partly because a lot of
things i'll get into it later but this
this thing was
a master class an absolute
banger i mean i forgot how many hits
they had
just one of the great shows i've ever
seen i'll talk about that here in a
second but yeah i mean that we did that
we saw a whole bunch of seinfeld things
uh to come up to uh tom's diner which
was uh monks and seinfeld um watch
baseball like crazy there's a there's a
mets bar
in the lower east side called standings
that maybe
guys you know how much i love dive bars
and you know how much i love pals in new
orleans
oh guys it is
way up there it might be one of the
great dive bars in the world wow i'm i
even for a non-sports guy like taco you
could walk in there and be like this is
badass i mean they've got
banners from the 70s still hanging in
the rafters
they've got all the sports weird
memorabilia everywhere
um you know
light beer on tap i was gonna say
taylormade
taylor made me make a good game yeah i
want to be there yeah they're making gin
and tonic for was brian okay with it
brian was all in on light draft year
that day all in i'm telling you he
didn't have a complaint he didn't have a
single complaint the entire weekend
that's that's going to be the podcast
that's what's going to be wrong
new york sucked i didn't
because i did everything
complained about it
[Music]
it was two nights yeah yeah yeah
everything every i love things too much
yeah when i needed a drink somebody was
right there to bring it to me i hate
that
i hate it
i mean there's just no no complaints i i
mean the man the man slept in every day
he he got everything he ever wanted um
you know i i still am sitting on
some major brian stone news
that i've never shared with anyone
and he's
pregnant
i'm waiting for the day to
to bring this up because i i just don't
feel comfortable
bringing it up without him right there
you can see the look on his face that
somebody's figured out a secret
i have discovered something about brian
stone that i don't think he's ever told
anybody and um
it's like it's like i've cracked the
code
and he's gonna be very
i don't know you're going to see it all
over his face you'll see it all over his
face and that no no bro no bro and then
it's going to like oh no okay
yeah
well there you go that's that's what you
get after spending 15 years
uh so
what else is i going to tell you uh oh i
wanted to start the show
off on something that i have been
obsessed with
for the last now two months since we
last were together
and that's this this new show
called lord taco's twitch
now
i
have no idea what i'm watching but i
love every second of it
please explain to me
what this is
because i'm so confused
it's just me playing video games and
drinking pbr on stream and
yeah ever since we've kind of taken a
break from the podcast i'd you know jump
back into it is that more time now so
um doing it three nights a week just
about
i i i understand that the i understand
the top line right i understand that you
playing video games and people just
watching it yeah but i'm
okay i'll start with a very easy
question what video games are these
they've never heard of any of these
games that you play
uh they're super nintendo games uh and
nintendo games uh earthbound final
fantasy you know oh final fantasy yeah
okay yeah old school rpg games that's
mostly what i played but it's just a
bunch of little
you know people walking around
you know a field
that sounds like baseball
from florida baseball expert
people walking around
what are you doing at this game like
what is the purpose of this game that
you play
well uh sometimes you do speed runs
which you try to uh beat it as fast as
possible and then you know
there's something
there's a leaderboard
uh beating the game
yeah what does that mean it means are
you collecting coins points
yeah what are you killing pete oh i mean
it's a it's a long game there's yeah
there's like a story and you progress
through the story i mean are you saving
a princess what are you doing
how is where are these random sound
effects coming from
uh every now and then just
you're playing the effects
well people in chat can play them yeah
okay now i'm starting to really get
confused so so there are people watching
in the chat room okay that screen that
i'm watching did you put all that
together or is that a twitch thing i put
it all together
so normally somebody who plays video
games on twitch doesn't have the three
screen thing like you do
well i mean it's however however you
want to lay it out if you want to put
your
camera up here and move the game over
here i mean it's however you want to set
it up but it's but twitch allows you to
do that right yeah
you design it however you want
okay all right so you didn't have to
come up with a whole mainframe and
create a
a
you know a code to make this thing work
mainframe and code i don't even know
what you're
well you
when you sign into twitch you get
options of a layout is that what i'm
guessing here no i do all that all
twitch does is just receive the video
stream that i send them okay so you did
have to create the the layout of the the
screen um i've done the layout
how did you do that
uh i use obs and uh you know create the
scene and then put all of my elements in
there and with the overlays and stuff
like that now see there you go that's
what i'm asking when i'm asking what is
the purpose of the game that kind of
detail all right so now
so now after i figure that part out you
now have three cameras okay so you have
a feed going into your tv
that's coming through your obs
then you have a camera just on pbr yep
and then you have a camera on you yeah
so you have a three camera setup that
you all put together that then is now uh
uh going out live while you're playing
okay so now i've got this figured out so
then there's a chat room now is that a
twitch thing or did you create that too
no that's a twitch thing when people
watch it on twitch they can they can
chat
okay and then they can execute commands
to make sound effects play to do
different video effects there's it's
very interactive
okay so it am i right to assume there
was one game that you've played in the
past where they can take over the game
or interject themselves yes
how does that happen
that's through a system called crowd
control where the game that i'm playing
you can create effects in the game like
you could make an enemy spawn
and attack like instantly so okay it's
not an earthbound
no
okay and and based on this yeah you can
do um as i say based on this
conversation i'm hoping you're also
commenting
that you're doing a lot of talking while
this is going on
yeah okay good
i mean a lot of talk talking in like
you know russ context
i mean he's not chatty cathy with this
but you know
for him it's a lot of words yes it is a
lot of words for us
okay all right so so the people that are
throwing things at you you know like the
sound effects and stuff you don't know
what's coming nope so somebody can just
hit a sound effect of a fart noise and
it'll it'll show up
yeah
okay all right now how distracting does
that become
it's not that distracting
i'm getting used to i know
is it is it it do they do it to disturb
you do they do it to get on your nerves
all of the above yeah okay but but do
they do it because you like it
okay
and how many people are usually watching
at one time
um 10 to 15.
wow
okay see barry like this is what's so
interesting about this and and
what i think taco doesn't understand is
like somebody like me who sees oh lord
taco is now live i just hit play and
watch it and i have no context
whatsoever is what's going on right
so it is the most
batshit crazy thing that i'm watching
like there's there's people screaming
there's a there's an emoji that pops up
you know there's a dancing baby all of a
sudden and then you know russ opens a
pbr like it's the strangest
you got it
sounds like a good tuesday night
i mean
it feels like every great cable access
show from our
childhood that plays like midnight
that you asked yes why is this on
television
yeah people making good money doing this
kind of thing
now has pbr reached out to you
no no not this okay no not once i've
reached out to them
okay no they never said anything no
all right well that's that was topic too
on the list of topics that i wanted to
get to this week
uh barry have you not watched the twitch
no i'm i'm gonna have to now okay
yeah okay
i can't wait to be thrilled now that you
know exactly what i know what's on deck
for this week
what are we playing this week taco uh i
don't know yet
probably just more of the same
okay okay um all right so
do we want to get into some of this news
do you guys have anything you want to
get to before uh
on some of the you know the less
important things
um
so a few months ago i was told by
uh
yeah just told by somebody
that you know matters but anyway it
doesn't matter um
and he predicted
that you will see
probably a dozen music festivals
say goodbye
this year
and the
um
the death of the music festival industry
is upon us
and since then
how many have we seen
do exactly that
not only
buku um
but you see things like that but then
you see the music midtowns completely
pull out because
of the gun law in
in georgia so i throw it to you
it it feels like there is uh
a shifting tide
the earth is shifting under our feet is
it
death of or culling of because that's
what we we talked about that uh i know i
mentioned it that it felt like we were
going to see
a culling that there were just too many
of them
and we were going to see a thinning
of the numbers i didn't predict the gun
thing
but it sure felt like there were just
too too many festivals and not enough
people and not enough money
um i mean is that pretty much what your
guy told you
are you talking about yeah okay yeah the
account yeah the economic things just
don't they're not sustained yeah you
could just feel it last year with you
know
so many of them not selling out and
numbers being down there were just too
many of them too many choices
uh
all the reasons we talked about you know
economy
gas uh
fact that we
we sort of lost the mojo you know two
and a half years that people kind of
lost
you know uh didn't feel like the the
fomo thing wasn't quite as strong as it
was before
you know
like okay i've missed them for two years
i can maybe miss another
whatever but uh
i i will say i reached out this morning
to a couple of people and bonnaroo is
not on that list i know we talked about
that
well i mean they just they just put out
that that uh we'll be back if you
remember we talked about there was uh
internal or
saber rattling that was going on with
the city and the county and some of the
businesses
i think what's going on figured it out
as we thought they would
uh
did this i don't know the details i
didn't get into that level i just asked
how are we feeling about next year and
they said we're we're all well real
quick real quick back real quick back up
because we actually never we wanted to
talk about this in detail uh months ago
but we never got to it so back up the
city was demanding more money from
bonnaroo because they lost their revenue
in 2020 the city and the city annex farm
which meant the county was losing that
revenue
and as part of the contract the county
was supposed to get a percentage of
sales based on the two previous years
which was zero uh so they were obviously
in a fix but then there were some local
businesses
uh that were
basically trying to make all their money
at once and and raising rates and that
sort of thing and it was going to cost
bonnaroo a lot more money and so there
was
you know there was some
going back and forth i you know i think
i said then i thought it would be
resolved
um
because you know you're don't look that
golden cow or golden goose you know
don't don't kill the golden goose
uh manchester's uh doesn't have a lot of
other options not certainly nothing like
that
uh so you know you kind of figured they
would work it out
like i said i only got a short answer
but it sounds like something was worked
out
um so
yeah
you know because we remind everybody i
mean uh what we we decided what 40 000
people was was what they had there um
you know i've been meaning to get the
the final count um i haven't i guess i
could i could ask huh yeah i mean there
was a lot of
people talking after it was all over i
mean there were a lot of things rush you
and i noticed uh you know security was
not nearly as
as vibrant shall we say as as it had
been in the past and uh fewer people
i mean one thing that i think uh
um
you know i i didn't even think about but
like this they didn't even give up you
talking about those t-shirts brad they
didn't even give those out to the staff
this year and that was another one yeah
think about that well they didn't even
do t-shirts
what wait what the what were the
volunteers wearing i suppose i never
stop it so how did you identify i don't
so so base so basically neon vest that
you know
county inmates wear when they're
cleaning up the yard
okay
uh but you know i mean a little thing
like that is a perk you know you go home
with a t-shirt um
they didn't even get t-shirts so
little i know right
things like that
yeah that saved them a lot of money
they are
expensive
you know
we know we've got plenty barry you want
to give some wages
yes plug the whatppodcast.com
that's right you can get all kinds of
merch i have some stickers left and some
koozies so
[Music]
maybe an orange vest
yeah
but anyway
it's they seem to have resolved it so
we'll see and uh i i will be curious um
as part of this conversation to see if
events like bonnaroo benefit from some
of these others going away
i
well maybe but but the big three you
know the of the big three only one
had a bad year you know the city
festivals are doing really well right
now because you know you have other
things to do um
in lollapalooza did just fine ala
palooza sold out acl's selling out uh
coachella did just fine um
so you know banru was the only one that
really struggled and
there's
four years why
well look let's put it this way for
years they were the standout because
they were a camping festival and that
which made them unique that was also the
reason why they probably struggled this
year more so than any other festival so
right it's a give-and-take yeah i'm
really really curious to see um i think
i think we sort of russ and i i know
that friday night maybe or was it
saturday i guess it was saturday night
because you were
you were asleep on friday night
uh but you and i were talking about you
know
what we would do next year
wait wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa what
why did russ fall asleep
again
he went hard on thursday yeah
he put his dinosaur costume on and uh we
didn't see him again till the morning
i was extinct
but i do remember you and i on that
saturday night you know i think we
talked about it on our last episode is
you know do we want to stay in media do
we want to go out to ga and you know
what might we do different next year and
um
i i i don't still don't know the answer
i'm glad i went but it was
well you have plenty of time to think
about it very well
but i'm not in a hurry to go experience
2022 again i know that much
well i mean
look it oh shoot sorry um no i think i
think what i would start wondering is
with the comment from uh a higher up at
a
in in the industry saying that you know
the
music festival business is in a really
tough spot you know you get music
midtown gone
you start wondering and looking around
and saying who might be next you know is
a four castle in trouble um
are you gonna get a shaky knees in
trouble uh these
these seem like no brainers that they
come back because they've been so
successful i mean shakiness is very
successful this year but you know the
economics of this is
they're really tricky at the second the
second that you have to jack up prices
25 percent it's going to really change
the way that you
um ask yourself uh can
we can this is dangerous and from a
local level we've got the river in what
three weeks four weeks uh three and a
half four weeks yep
three or four weeks it's not sold out
it's it's not sold our sales for that by
the way didn't sell out here for the
first time in three or four years
and
i mean they're only selling yeah
depending on how they how they configure
it each year but uh
right about that yeah i think they're
close from what i understand
but not sold out and then i understand
to your your point just a second ago
that our the riverbend festival
which is local almost 40 years old
totally redid it this year
went from
an unlimited number of admission
to a 15 000 cap which they hit
but it basically
basic
it just about broke even from what i
understand and part of that was because
of a two million dollar
um
was it a grant that the government
gave to um
uh
entertainment yeah i think some grant or
whatever you call it but basically a
grant um and so
you know that that's a big a big
bunch of money to get that you can't
count on next year
so like you said they're probably
looking at
raising ticket prices
i mean
i haven't i haven't tracked the money
follow the dollar but i wonder how many
of these music festivals got bailed out
during
covid with with these kinds of programs
and you just made a really really
great point in that can survive them
this year but how does it bring back
next year hence you're seeing a lot of
these cancel you know look
i think that we all universally think
that um firefly did a nice job and our
buddy sean is now booking that firefly
festival and i think that he did a great
job booking it but it's not sold out
and firefly always does well these
second-tier festivals i think are in
real real trouble
um now i know that there's conspiracy
theories going around about music
midtown because you know they're trying
to hide behind the gun law and maybe
they weren't selling as many tickets
well you know look i i don't think they
were selling as many tickets as they
thought but i was absolutely
one million percent um
reiterated to that it was the gun law
and even if they are doing a really good
job messaging that
and getting everybody on the same page
and and and making that the point
yeah
i believe him
i believe him um but it is it is
good timing if you want to get out of
the business it's a good time to not not
just start
not just allocating dollars somewhere
else you know
i hate to again be doom and gloomy but
not having an event for two
years
has to be hard
i mean
well i actually don't think it's doom
and gloom barry i think it makes the
ones that survive better
i think the reason why we are so bummed
out in some of the bonnaroo and some of
the other festival lineups is because
we've seen it happen
it happened last week and it happened
before that and half the week before
that like how many more times do we have
to carbon copy the same successful
lineup over and over and so
and it goes back to a conversation that
we had with um
cuellar and and other professionals is
these these more curated experiences
these experiences these places that have
really uh special
uh
identities and brands they're the ones
that are going to probably survive more
than others and you know your your
regular music festival that's in your
you know
in your hometown or in your region yeah
they're probably the ones that are yeah
it has to have that
special reason i mean you you can see
banned xyz
almost anywhere it's what what's
surrounding it um
i mean look gov ball was a as was a mess
this year absolute mess
uh does that something like that survive
next year
why would it need to
it was in it was in the city field
parking lot for christ's sakes what kind
of brand experience do you think you're
going to get
on yeah right well i i know we're gonna
i know when you're successful that's a
fair woodstock 99 too but it it all
a lot of this is um
i mean i just watched it this week
and it was stunning to me to see the
progression from 1999 to 2002 when
bonnaroo started
um
and then where we are now and it's all
about
i know well don't don't get too much
into
well somebody told me that and you tell
me if i'm right right or wrong but
somebody told me that it was more
not putting the onus on the musicians
and putting it more on the promoters
that the first one was way too
blaming
you know
the bands yeah there was a lot of yeah
um
it was a lot more emphasis on how women
were treated in this one even though it
was mentioned in the first one
that was a big big issue and uh we you
know we can get into that or we can wait
till next time when you've seen it
because i
okay
uh kind of what we were just saying is
as we've learned and the reason you and
i and and taco are doing this podcast is
we've just appreciated
that level of um
customer service and branding
that bonnaroo has had
um
you know thanks to guys like jeff
cuellar i mean just
guys who who wake up and think what
would i want
you know as a fan what do i want i want
water i want shade i want comfort i want
you know a 24-hour experience
well
well i will say bringing it back home
if there's anything that bonner has been
really really good at in the last 16 17
years barry
uh they're fantastic listeners
and there's very rarely a time there's
something happens on that farm where
they don't hear it and reacts in some
positive way to it so
uh i have no inside
track on this but i can promise you
whatever was said this year they heard
it which brings me
to my demands now okay um i have some
demands i do i have some demands i've
spent two months three months now in new
york four months i'm sorry four months
in new york and i
have come away with a few things that i
am absolutely demanding bonnaroo
consider and do
um and this is not because it's not
self-serving
uh although it's self-serving all right
so
all right i am starting demand number
one
i cannot believe
after 16 years 17 years however long
this festival has been around i cannot
believe
that not one time
they have they have booked rage against
a machine
it is almost derelict of duty
that the one of the greatest rock bands
on the planet has played coachella how
many times
have done how many tours now
few and far between
but never once come to bonnaroo
i
am out of my mind in love with this rage
show that i saw on monday now you're
seeing somebody who is i'm a casual rage
against a machine fan
i like them
i know their songs i know it was going
to be good
barry i didn't know it was going to be
incredibly great i had no idea that
first off you forget that there's only
three guys putting out that sound
outside of zach there's only three guys
making that thing feel so big
not only that you forget how great of a
guitar player tom morello is
you say it in your head oh yeah tom rowe
great guitar player oh no no no no no no
no
he's not great
he's
the greatest guitar player alive
and
it is incredible how he keeps that whole
operation sounding pitch [ __ ] perfect
every note is perfect
it's insane
third
zach had a broken leg which i think made
the show better
he had to sit on a gear box
he had to sit on it well it didn't feel
like he
he only had to do vocals right so he
didn't have to like bounce around the
stage and make a no no he just had to
make the vocals right so he had to sit
on a box and he had so much energy on
this box it almost felt like sometimes
when he was spinning around spinning
around putting his leg in the air it
felt like he was levitating he had so
much energy coming off of that box
um is that why they say break a leg when
you go out on stage literally yeah
you'll be better you'll be a better
performer
fourth
i have never seen a show at madison
square garden before
but
the only thing that's ever come close to
the almost perfection of sound that is
on the what stage is what i just heard
of madison square garden
oh my god barry this venue
i i've never i've never heard a venue
better
aside from bonnaroo's what stage it may
have been the best sounding venue i've
ever been into in my life
every seat is padded and comfortable
uh
i i i can't tell you how much i love
this entire experience
fifth
the the knock on rage is
too negative for bonnaroo
not the right kind of energy
and
man if that's the argument
uh
i want to point you to the screen that
that they have behind them whereas
during some of the songs they were
posting names and stories of social
justice
people who have been
abused by police
social justice warriors a celebration of
people who have helped putting um
people's stories up that have haven't
been told before that have been
forgotten
people who have been
completely used by the system or or
abused by the police
they they throw these stories on and
there's nothing to me
more bonnaroo
than rage against the machine and how
they are social justice warriors in in
trying to affect change in all of the
right spaces
that's amazing
how have they not who's
against the machine and i'm sitting here
thinking that tool show wasn't exactly a
big warm fuzzy hug was it taco i mean
talk about the video
well i mean look um killing in the name
of uh you know you can you can find
people who who would say that's just not
the right sound in fact i i got a few i
got a few messages it's just not the
sound the bonnaroo is known for it i
just i just don't i don't buy it i don't
agree with it um
nobody
in our generation has been able to write
songs and put a message out
in lyrics
this profound and this impactful
in what in a generation
why why what what is keeping you from i
understand the the
rationales that we've heard before you
know not everything works you know the
tory
there should be no debate here
get rage or nobody
[Music]
this is this is the one last ban that
you haven't gotten and you can make an
argument about the stones but give me a
break you know this is real this is a
react
a real ban that you could absolutely go
get
why are you not throwing money at them
that would be the single biggest thing
they could do to get back um
into who we know bonnaroo is second
demand
second demand
i demand bonnaroo
bring
celo green
to be the host of the next super jam
all right ceelo green did an album with
dan arbok now uh dan arbok made him do
this this beautiful sort of pentecostal
church teddy pendergrass album it didn't
get heard for a long time because ceelo
was in a
a bit of a metoo mess and not of a bit
it was of his own creation and he just
kept making it worse so he he damn near
ruined his career with his metoo moment
well
the album gets put out and now he's
doing shows he did one at jazz fest
all
tribute and a dedication to james brown
where they're all wearing a jumpsuit
where it says brown automotive on the
back of it so they're going effortlessly
through james brown's catalog through
his catalog
through meatloaf to
celine dion they are weaving so many
hits
through the james brown catalog and it's
done with an absolute stunner of a band
behind him absolute stunner
now be
ceelo you know can you know here nor
there but imagine ceelo hosting
the super jam
with dan arbach
half an hour away in nashville
and you see the drama that's around the
black keys right now and patrick
carney's you know
whatever is going on with him and
michelle branch
but i don't think the black keys are
going to be touring much longer
considering the drama that's happening
between them so you're gonna get dan
sitting on his hands in nashville
already produced an album with with
ceelo
bring it down
let him curate a james brown
super jam
well what are we
this is this is a slam dunk yeah why not
wasn't he uh wasn't he unofficially
banned though
[Laughter]
but he's not on anybody's short list to
invite back anytime soon to put it that
way
but whatever all right so i want to hear
the other demands i can't wait to see
these so the
well so so the the knock on ceilo the
reason why you would say he can't do it
is because of his metoo movement and to
that i would say i hear you
i'm not discounting it but
they had no problem putting all-time low
on the bill and they had no problem
putting machine gun kelly on the bill
now
they might have been missteps and
they might have regretted it but there
is precedent for them to
bypass
you know certain indiscretions or or
problems and
an artist pass
um okay
i i
the the rest of my demands are not so
much demands although they are gentle
pushes
all right
um
it is time for us to look around and
celebrate
the
uh friend of the shows duran jones and
indications and aaron frazier
uh one of the great
shows i have seen now twice
this past year and two years aaron
frazier at acl and now aaron frazier at
a small brooklyn club
right around from our house
duran jones is going to have a new album
aaron frazier is is slowly going to be a
solo superstar i am betting i don't know
why uh we're not putting durian jones uh
and booking them
almost immediately and then finally
uh it is time
to bring julian baker
and
angel olsen
and
sharon vonnetten
back to bonnaroo and let them curate an
entire female empowerment experience
um i think that the
the best female artists that we have on
the planet right now brandy carlisle
sharon vonnetten
phoebe bridgers maggie rogers julian
baker this group
is
a
knockout
they
they're the best
we are in a
almost a golden age of female performers
and they're getting zero love on the
radio they're selling out everywhere
they're streaming everywhere
i don't know why we're not
i don't know why we're not putting all
of them
with bonnaroo's problem with women
and their first headliner being lizzo
and then stevie nicks
man now's the time now's the time to
just bring them all
do whatever you can i mean that those
those girls are are are in nashville
do it bring them all
make make an entire day an entire stage
dedicated to
just
female liberation
[ __ ] the patriarchy
you know put him all on one stage and
let him run do something completely
different completely out of the box
give him an entire plaza too
this is there's
i i don't i don't see why not at this
point
it's time you're done
there you go oh oh you know i hope
you're listening
so uh taco
do you want to reach out to stephen and
brian up there in knoxville and uh tell
them tell them guys it's done you know
your work is done brad's done it all for
you
do you want me to because i'm happy to
share
believe me i'm sending this recording to
the scene they're gonna be thrilled
they would have no idea
yeah yeah solved all your problems guys
they love getting these kind of notes i
know who you should get
look it's it's not so much about who you
can get it's that um
this
we're in a time now where it calls for
sort of a different approach to things
the standard operating playbook and all
of these things are just not going to
work as well as they did in the past
it's time to do something different i
think that's and
we've been saying that yeah for the last
three or four episodes that this whole
year felt like a do-over it's a it's a
reset and i i mean i i still think so
we didn't have you know
um
the suggestions and the demands like you
like you've just put forward so you know
you've had time to think about it well i
think i'll tell you i'll tell you why i
i've
i've had a lot of time to think about it
and i and i don't say this as some sort
of like uppity all of a sudden walking
but didn't it
when you're here
well i don't want it to sound like that
no i don't understand like the reason i
say this because i've seen more shows in
the last four months than i probably did
in four years even including bonnaroo
right and so
when
i i've been so
like jumped into this pool and swimming
around it and i start looking around
first off it's the reason why i didn't
need to like break my neck to get to
bonnaroo or lollapalooza this year is
because every week is a music festival
here right the the challenge is to stop
yourself and to not do something but
i've seen enough of these shows now to
say to myself
you know
doing the same old thing and finding the
same old artists are just not gonna
they're not gonna fair enough
fair enough
i don't think that that's being you know
well i mean
you know not everybody got to see rage
at madison square garden
i know that's why i want them to i
demand them to bring them to bondurant i
demand it
i will be i will be your fighter
bonnaroovians i will be your warrior
because i will not rest you will hear me
say it every episode on this goddamn
podcast from now until bonnaroo 2022
i'd like to say
i don't know why they've been spring
rage
i would love to have them there yeah
that is it i i just can't if it was that
good of madison square garden
i wish how good it would be on friday
night probably the our next episode uh
maybe russ and i can come up with our
list of demands that's a little strong
for me
uh what what i don't know that i have a
list i love that yeah taco based on
more blue hairs based on last year i
mean
you know what
changes need to be made i know you know
we
we talked about you know they moved us
from the trees but that's a personal
thing and there were issues with the
yeah
okay
no but there were the issues with the
making everything about me jam tracks
and some of the games and some of those
sorts of things you know maybe we ought
to think
and um
come up with our own list of
changes
um
right right
i'm not asking for a lot of changes i'm
asking i'm asking for that i'm asking
for them to rethink how they well
it was interesting
now we're talking about lineup being you
know we've we've all the last couple of
years we've sort of been line up is
important but it's not all encompassing
and
i i does it feel like this year the
lineup is going to be very important i
mean would you yeah yeah
exactly
oh yeah
oh yeah absolutely and look look i just
if if we go down this path of you know
come october and november when we're
doing lineup hunting and we are you know
throwing out our mock lineups and saying
you know my wish list is this this and
this
man i tell you if we come to january
february when the lineup gets announced
and it's the same old load of crap
we're all going to be like we don't care
anymore i'm telling you you're just not
gonna care anymore i i know the
experience is is wonderful and we're
gonna all talk about how great we love
that yes we do
but at some point i don't agree you've
got to do something different this last
year was a yeah you know i talked about
it it was a lot it was a work year for
me which i knew and it was also
a different kind of thing for a variety
of reasons but there was nobody on that
lineup
that was a must must see for me there
were a lot of people that i wanted to
see and you know
but there was no
bucket list or can't believe i saw
uh
act and certainly as a as an entirety
it wasn't like that you know
still had a good time
but yeah i i think you're right i think
they'll hear you
the lineup better come strong
better be one of those i can't miss it
you know type of lineup yep
i can't miss it that's right yeah that's
right that's what they need um
all right um that's that's all i got
yeah i want you to watch there's a lot
of stuff
because i really i want to talk about it
russ have you watched it no i'll watch
it this week okay all right so that's
our watch out today we'll try to
reconvene next week what do you say guys
when it was after it was over it really
stuck with me that it was in 1999
obviously and then bonnaroo was three
years later
and the transition not just from
festivals but social society yeah just
all kinds of things watch it with that
in mind
all right
all right love you guys okay
all right you're the best
talk to you guys soon
[Music]
[Music]
consequence podcast network